hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel it is xbox showcase day today
and i got to speak
to some of the team at 343 a little bit
more about halo infinite to share some
details with you guys so this is going
to be probably a pretty quick video
i just kind of wanted to share what i
learned today and while i feel like some
people
seem to be very disappointed about the
presentation all i really wanted was
halo gameplay and that fable
announcement and we got both
so i'm good i feel like i just don't buy
into the hype
very much for these conferences anymore
which means i'm never let down and it's
a good place to be
to cut to the chase uh i'm going to
rewatch the halo gameplay reveal
in 4k uh it seems like that probably
makes a pretty significant difference
but also i'm going to stop
occasionally and talk to you guys about
some of the things on screen because i
got a behind closed doors demo of halo
infinite which basically
means uh it was chrisley and paul
crocker talking us through
some of the choices they made and then i
also got to ask the team some questions
to get some clarification
on halo before we uh watch the trailer i
did want to say
a couple of like major things that they
told me or that i asked or that someone
else in my session asked
uh i did ask if we will be going to
other worlds they said they wanted to
keep some secrets which makes me assume
that yes
there will be more than one world that
we visit in halo infinite and one of the
biggest questions that i had that i feel
like i'm slowly piecing together
is if it is an open world game and i do
actually feel like gameplay-wise it is
probably going to be
this seems so weird to make this
comparison but it's
new and um just easy to relate though i
understand how strange this is going to
sound
it's also just like this gameplay of it
on my channel so you could go look at
that if you want to
think of the way that the open world is
in goes to tsushima
you have some gold objectives and you
have some silver objectives uh the gold
objectives are the main quest
the silver objectives are side things
and then you have those extra tails
which are extra
side objectives in one big open world
that does
slowly kind of open up a bit more seems
like that's what halo infinite is
basically going to be
from everything that i can tell and from
what i asked it is supposed to be a sort
of broad
expansive world a full sandbox with a
bunch of stuff for players to discover
but there is still absolutely a very um
they said epic
personal story so very much a story
focus uh it would just be that if you
want to go do a main story
mission you just go and do that but you
can also
play around in the sandbox or do side
quests if you want to
again like a ghost of tsushima there are
obviously many other games that do that
i am kind of getting anthem vibes where
that is concerned i did ask if there was
a hub location and they didn't answer
but yeah some important things to note
is that it seems like you don't actually
have to do the story missions you can
kind of just do whatever if you don't
want to do them but if you do
they have put a hell of a lot of effort
into that story uh you only play
as a spartan there is split screen a
four-player co-op in any one world
and you would all be spartans so it's
not like some of you would be some other
character
um the pilot who is the guy that let's
just stop playing the trailer i'm
excited to see it
in 4k let's make sure we're actually
playing
no no no no no no we gotta go we gotta
actually 4k this
like i've seen so this is the pilot um
he's supposed to be a very important
character i think he's gonna be like yo
cortana he's the human
to balance out the chief they said he's
like the most normal guy they could have
made
but obviously bertsa back they did say
that uh
brutes will be able to throw grunts at
you
um yeah i was going to say i saw people
complain that they didn't think that the
graphics were
good frankly people were saying they
think the graphics are bad and i just
don't
have any problem with it because to me
it looks like classic halo so that's
what i want i guess um but this is
uh in progress they did say it's an led
but i'm very much cool with how it looks
so yeah it is a chief centric story it
is a sequel to halo 5
but it is very much focused on the
future and they did say that you will
absolutely not need to have played any
other halo game to be able to
understand this game though if you
haven't i recommend that you do
i don't [ __ ] with four or five so much
but the early halo games including
reaching odst
good stuff
uh and the main thing that they just
kept pressing on was
this technology will save humanity from
what i can tell as a response to
criticism um is we built this to be a
love-lettered halo this is
very much a uh spiritual sequel
sorry no spiritual reboot they were so
focused on making sure it feels like
halo and i was actually told
i cannot fail
no not officially that um
halo infinite was delayed was originally
going to come out sooner but they
reworked the story because
the fan response to halo 5 was fairly
negative so they they kind of
re-envisioned things and and are really
kind of restarting
it's nothing halo it's just insane that
that's
this is such a good one you step inside
um yeah they said it's the most open
expansive environment they've ever
created
several times larger than the last two
campaigns put together
which is nuts um there's a new equipment
system with the sandbox obviously the
drop shield and the grapple which is
called the grapple shot
uh there's a new audio engine i feel
like that's most of the news that i got
and um i did just interview aaron
greenberg
on youtube.com inside gaming check it
out and obviously you know
pass for a release date they just not
given it to us yet uh i feel like
there's going to be another showcase
maybe at some point
which it seems crazy to get this many in
a year but
that seems to be the approach so we'll
probably find out
i think the halo infinite obviously a
launch title um release date alongside
the price of the xbox series x probably
at the same time
but yeah mostly just wanted to try to
explain a little bit about how uh
the open world is going to work it is
very much a system where you you know
run into objectives or set a point on a
map and then
navigate and explore as you go that's
absolutely the goal which is definitely
a change to halo that i initially was
very against but then when i think about
you know ghost tsushima was still a
satisfying story to me so i feel like
halo probably will be able to pull this
off especially when you think about
halo's focus on vehicles halo has always
been fun to traverse
uh i've had instances where you know
it's been scripted that i have to get
out of a scorpion and i'm kind of
annoyed about it because i was like
but i want to keep using my tank whereas
i feel like
they are very much taking advantage of
the plethora
of vehicles and how much fans love those
vehicles when approaching this
so yeah that's most of the information
keeping this largely fact-based um
not very opinionated on this one i guess
it i realized today that there are a lot
of people who really want to hate this
game which is cool
uh you do you fam and if you like halo
that's also cool
i don't feel like i'm necessarily 100
sold on this but
um i'm more interested in playing halo
infinite than i was in
ever touching halo 5 which you know i
have touched but
but these are just some extra facts i
got for you all
if you have any questions i will do my
best to answer them below um because i
did get to talk to
you know microsoft employees for about
an hour total
today across everything i can't promise
that i can answer everything but i'll do
my best so
that's it for this quick video i am
happy to
be i don't know kind of excited about
halo again
it feels good to me man and i think that
that's because it does look like classic
halo
so i am cool with it alrighty guys i
will see you all next time